-We want to play a game with you
because we found out that
one of your favorite
golf movies,
maybe even your favorite,
is "Happy Gilmore."
-It certainly is.
Everyone loves "Happy Gilmore."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It is time for
the "Happy Gilmore Putting
Challenge" with Rory McIlroy.
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now here's how it works.
Instead of using golf clubs,
we'll putt using a hockey stick
just like Adam Sandler did
in "Happy Gilmore."
In fact, there he is
right over there.
What's up, Sandman?
We're going to put 30 seconds
on the clock.
Whoever makes more putts before
time runs out is the winner.
I'll be using the yellow balls.
You'll be using
the little white balls.
-Perfect.
[ Laughter ]
-Ready for this?
-Ready.
-All right. Time starts...now.
Go.
-Oh, no.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh! Oh, no.
♪♪♪♪
-One time.
Oh, no!
♪♪♪♪
I'm going two at a time.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
No!
[ Buzzer ]
-Judges.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's a tie!
-No!
-Yes!
I love that.
I will keep that as a tie.
My man Rory McIlroy, everybody.